tous les jeunes gens les gens maintenant
ils chantent à sécuriser avec tous ceux
qui se dit et tout parce que la plupart
du temps je sais pas des gens qui
viennent discuter avec nous on voit
qu'ils diront regardez-moi ces voyous
c'est ceux qui nous ont jamais vu qui
nous connaissent même pas puis qui se
permettent de nous juger qui diront ça
on a foutu là dedans ce qu'on a ramassé
les cloches des bidon il laisse des
beaux quartiers
menace d'expulsion il aurait
l'innovation
pour le profilé Grosso et puis les
grands patrons
on y a racheté un soupçon d'émigré
des travailleurs de ces quelques
handicapés
des gens qui se moquent sont aussi bien
ici
plutôt que de croupier pardiments de
taudis moi je vais vous dire une chose
très sincèrement je préfère être ici que
d'habiter le centre de Lyon ça c'est
certain je veux dire on y voit encore au
niveau des espaces verts on y aperçoit
quelques arbres bien mais dans votre
environnement il n'y a que des familles
immigrées est-ce que la cohabitation se
passe bien alors moi je dis qu'au niveau
de la cohabitation avec les familles
d'immigrées ça ne nous pose aucun
problème le problème il vient pas de là
le problème il vient de la du fait qu'on
a mis ensemble des gens avec des
problèmes je veux dire que bon
c'est pas
c'est pas nier qu'il y a bon un fort
pourcentage de chômage que bon si on est
entouré de famille immigrées les
travailleurs donc les les pères de
famille et ben je suis désolé mais ils
pas les reines de notre administration
ils sont pas cadres ils sont tout
simplement
manœuvres donc
il vit ils vivent des conditions de vie
pas toujours pas toujours agréable il
faut le reconnaître pour pour chaque
jour je dis que nous au sein de de cette
communauté on est des privilégiés on a
la possibilité de partir en vacances de
de sortir de là et ça nous pèse alors on
comprend très bien que pour ces gens qui
passent doucement de leur vie ici dans
les enfants passent deux mois et demi au
pied des immeubles mais ça peut devenir
il peut naître une violence incroyable
on peut pas tirer dessus
de m'inter pour de m'interposer pour
essayer de faire signe d'arrêter vos
véhicules
sans
problème quoi c'est un jeu ma foi
plus tard dans la nuit cette voiture
volée on la retrouvera en train de
brûler un scénario qui se répète
maintenant quasi quotidiennement dans la
banlieue de Lyon à Villeurbanne à Bron
ou à vous en Velin et ceci depuis le
mois de juillet toujours le même
scénario d'abord un vol d'automobile en
général grosse cylindrée un rodéo dans
les rues de la ville l'incendie de la
voiture et enfin des jets de pierre sur
les fourgons de police secours alors
arrivé sur les lieux les coupables des
jeunes semble-t-il des loubards comme
l'on dit ici
ces événements de la banlieue lyonnaise
les journaux les ont relatés avec force
détail dès le mois de juillet les titres
chocs ont succédé au titre à sensation
pour les médias la ZUP des Minguettes
est devenue l'espace d'un été le Bronx
Chicago Liverpool les jeunes qui ont
vécu ces événements ne gardent pas un
bon souvenir du passage de l'actualité
chez eux
[Musique]
pendant l'été là il y a quelques
journalistes qui sont venus ils ont
raconté n'importe quoi que c'était un
ghetto que c'était
je sais pas quoi la ville en feu je sais
pas quoi n'importe quoi quoi et en fin
de compte c'est pas vrai tout ce qu'ils
ont dit certains qui sont venus là ils
ont fait les gentils et tout ils
embauchent même des des petits pour qui
brûlent quelques voitures pour qu'il
brûle quelques voitures et les ont payé
les journalistes un pour qui brûlent ces
voitures vous l'avez vu ça
ils ont dit et ils nous ont même posé
des trucs vous voulez pas voler une
petite BM ce soir pour pour qu'on fasse
un peu un petit film là
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces
procédés c'est les journalistes comme ça
qui nous ont qui nous ont coulé quoi qui
nous ont croisés
parce que il y a quand même eu des
problèmes de voiture brûlées au départ
mais ça c'est comme partout
il y en a deux ou trois bon il brûle des
voitures et tout ça c'est la plupart
c'est des petits hein faut pas croire
que c'est des grands bandits parce que
brûler une voiture c'est pas difficile
on dit pas qu'on est des seins on dit
pas on vole pas mais ils disent la
plupart c'est nous qu'on qu'on fait les
viols qu'on fait les vols qu'on fait
qu'on casse tout euh
de quoi ils disent qu'on fait tout quoi
c'est à cause de nous qui a du chômage
c'est à cause de Nokia qui a ça va pas
et tout mais c'est pas vrai tout ça bon
d'accord il y en a certains qui sont
attrapés en train de voler mais les
Français aussi sont attrapés en train de
voler un il y a pas un que les Arabes
mais seulement seulement les vols les
vols et les les viols et tout les
journalistes ils mettent les Algériens
sur les journals voyez pas vous voyez
aucun nom de viol français et tout parce
qu'ils veulent pas les mettre sur
journal parce que comme ça ils disent
tout ça ça vient des Algériens les gens
quand ils regardent les journal Mohamed
Mohamed et tout voilà parler
oh minguette sur 35000 habitants 20 000
en moins de 25 ans ces jeunes sont en
majorité d'origine immigrée s'ils ne
sont pas tous nés aux mains guet tous
ils ont effectué leur scolarité
aujourd'hui dans les écoles de la ZUP
plus de 70% des élèves sont des immigrés
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se souvient quel est dans
certaines classes les enfants
représentent 17 nationalités différentes
parmi ceux qui entreront en sixième 1
sur 10 seulement parviendra au bac
une grande partie des enfants rejette
l'école et s'il y a eu des événements
cet été les fameux rodéo dont on a trop
parlé je crois que c'est le fruit d'un
certain d'une certaine évolution qui
dure depuis déjà 10 ans nous en 1974 75
nous avions déjà attiré l'attention des
pouvoirs publics en disant attention
signe se fait rien pour les enfants dans
la ZUP ses enfants dans quelques années
vont être adolescents l'école ils l'ont
rejeté ou l'école les a rejetés ce qui
revient exactement le résultat c'est
qu'on a eu effectivement un très grand
nombre d'enfants qui sont sortis de la
scolarité sans rien sans même parfois
savoir lire on s'aperçoit par exemple le
samedi matin vous avez dans les classes
7 8 10 enfants qui ne sont pas là et
pourquoi ne sont-ils pas là et bien tout
simplement parce qu'ils vont gagner un
peu d'argent au marché à déballer les
colis pour les forains pour les
marchands forains c'est un drame en soi
Paul l'école de la ZUP a une mauvaise
image de marque une mauvaise image de
marque de par le fait que il s'y passe
des choses dans les écoles de la ZUP des
maquettes il se passe par exemple
c'était ces dernières années à chaque
weekend une école qui était ça continue
ça continue ça c'est un petit peu
atténué cette dernière année mais l'an
dernier il faut rappeler qu'il y a eu
quand même trois écoles incendiées à
Vénissieux trois écoles incendiées de
par le fait sûrement d'enfants les
saccages d'école par exemple lorsque
nous y allons le lundi matin lorsqu'on
nous appelle nous voyons les traces de
pas ce sont des enfants des
petits-enfants parfois qui commettent ce
genre de ce genre de choses pour eux
c'est un jeu un peu moins fréquemment
maintenant on a l'impression que ça
c'est un peu calmé quoique quoique moi
j'ai trouvé personnellement mon école
saccagé avant-hier matin en rentrant
deux classes complètement saccagées avec
des dégâts assez important ça arrive
encore
un très grand nombre d'enfants quittent
l'école primaire avec un deux voire
trois voire quatre ans de retard
effectivement quand un enfant quitte
l'école primaire avec deux ou trois ans
de retard c'est le client rêvé pour les
classes parking qui sont le qui était
auparavant les classes de transition qui
sont maintenant les classes
préprofessionnelles de niveau des ces là
effectivement c'est des clients rêvés
pour la délinquance plus tard je crois
que là s'il y a un drame véritable
[Musique]
je m'appelle
boujadi Saïd je suis né le 22 12 62 ça
fait que je vais à 19 ans au mois de
décembre
on est 7 gosses chez moi en 4 frères et
trois sœurs
j'ai fait mes études ici là j'ai eu un
CAP de mécanicien auto
j'ai travaillé en tout peut-être deux
ans en tout moment pour un an et demi
le programme handicap c'est qu'on est
jeune soit disant qu'à la télé ils ont
dit Pôle emploi mais quand on va ils
disent non il faut un gars qu'à 25 ou 30
ans et qui a déjà 5 ans et d'expérience
bon il y a un gars comme lui il a pas
d'expérience ni lui moi j'en ai bon j'ai
4 ans et d'expérience dans mon métier
quoi j'ai un CAP de mécanicien auto mais
quand je vais dans une boîte il m'a
embauche pas bon déjà ça fait deux
handicaps le troisième je sais que on
est où et nord-africain c'est qu'on est
dans africain et quatrième handicap bon
s'il leur africain ça passe c'est
l'expérience ça passe si là j'y passe on
en a quatrième handicap c'est l'adresse
si je viens je dis j'habite et à Corbas
ça va ou à Feyzin mais là si si j'arrive
devant une boîte qui me prenne et puis
je sors ma carte de résidence comme ça
m'est arrivé chez marceletto là qu'on La
Fayette sans ma carte de résidence il
est mon adresse rue de la démocratie non
non et on vous écrira ou carrément me
demande est-ce que c'est votre ancienne
adresse votre nouvelle adresse alors je
dis non c'est là où j'habite ah bon vous
écrira ou mon téléphone ça veut dire
quoi ça ça veut dire que Edwin
parce qu'on est en africain et étant
donné qu'on habite là il y a des
voitures qui sont brûlées ou qu'il y a
des voitures sans voler alors ils
croient que si on si on travaille dans
la boîte on va taper et la caisse on va
voler et les outils on va voler dans les
voitures des clients c'est pas vrai ça
mais de la délinquance ici il y en a il
y en a il y en a il y en aura toujours
eu mais il y en a ça c'est vrai on peut
pas nier mais ça c'est minime alors que
on est on est 15000 jeunes au chômage à
Vénissieux il y en a pas 20 ou 30 il y
en a 15000 au chômage garçon et fille
hein
Saïd se trompe il n'y a pas 15000
chômeurs aux Minguettes mais 4000 c'est
déjà beaucoup car cette situation est
souvent mal vécue dans les familles
[Musique]
est-ce que les parents comprennent
toujours que leurs enfants soient au
chômage
ils comprennent mais tant que c'est les
autres qui sont en chômage ça va mais
quand c'est quelqu'un de la famille ça
va par exemple on va chercher du boulot
tout on passe des matinées à chercher du
boulot dans les cars et tout mais quand
on rentre et on dit qu'on n'a pas trouvé
de boulot sa gueule et tout ils disent
qu'on va traîner et tout un garçon il
faut absolument qu'il travaille une
fille bon bah si elle trouve pas bon bah
tu restes à la maison
on est là en t'aidera tu te marieras
c'est ça leur avenir pour nous c'est ça
nous intéresse pas on a été à l'école on
veut travailler on veut vivre ils
comprennent pas ça les parents
puis
on se présente comme moi je me présente
plusieurs fois je passe des tests je
suis pas j'attends une réponse une
semaine deux semaines j'ai reçu trois
lettres en une semaine comme quoi
j'étais pas prise alors là je suis
vraiment déprimée je m'arrête pendant
deux trois semaines je cherche plus du
tout de travail parce que quand on
cherche pendant deux semaines c'est vrai
on se lève le matin on cherche puis d'un
coup on reçoit des lettres on trouve
plus de travail ça énerve complètement
là ça fait trois semaines il m'a envoyé
un télégramme pour travailler la zone
industrielle
j'ai été là-bas c'était sur machine
à bouton automatique là j'ai été voir le
chef là-bas je me suis présenté je
donnais la convocation tout il m'a dit
vous habitez où je dis rue vous êtes
français ou je dis ouais je présente mes
papiers et puis il m'a dit fin de compte
ce sera trop dur pour vous tout ça
puis je suis reparti les mêmes diplômes
et tout et au moment où on arrive pour
se présenter et ben si par exemple même
si on est meilleur c'était nous on quoi
dans la branche
le métier que l'on a fait et ben on
choisira plutôt une Française qu'une
algérienne et ça c'est une
discrimination qui ne devrait pas
exister puisque l'on n'avait cuit ici
puisqu'on a poursuivi les mêmes études
puisque plus qu'on a eu des notes comme
tout le monde et ben on devrait avoir un
diplôme un emploi comme pareil aux
autres mais autrement questionnepe
police c'est exactement pareil dans
l'absolu qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous désireriez qu'est-ce que vous
voudriez
fixe
l'essentiel c'est que ce soit fixe
on est comme tout le monde parce qu'on
parle plus de nous que quelqu'un d'autre
que on demande comme tout le monde la
même chose du travail c'est tout le
respect des gens c'est tout ça doit être
grave là
problème qui se fait là c'est un
problème jaune façon le chômage le
chèque scolaire tout ça ça se retrouve
de partout de toute façon c'est pas
spécifique au baguette
cette difficulté pour les jeunes de
trouver du travail et spécialement pour
les jeunes maghrébins nous est confirmé
par un employé de l'ANPE de Vénissieux
nous sommes sollicités régulièrement par
des entreprises qui
en premier ou en deuxième temps
font une discrimination oui nous
recommande de ne pas présenter ni de
Maghrébins ni de noir ni de bon
à bien sûr à chaque intervention de ce
type là on le rappelle les textes de la
loi mais j'ai le sentiment que ils ont
toutes facilité pour la bafouer mais
vous êtes complice
on était moins
mais
n'a pas toujours non plus
les moyens qui nous permettent de
l'intervenir mais souvent on n'a pas
dans l'entreprise de courage de dire aux
jeunes je ne veux pas de vous parce que
vous êtes maghrébin mais
on leur dit pour faciliter les choses on
peut par l'acheter aussi on leur dit ben
poster pourvu alors le jeune n'a plus
qu'à faire demi-tour elle va revenir
dans le service avec un petit peu
d'agressivité au coeur parce que nous
dit qu'on m'avait envoyé là-bas et le
postulait déjà pourvu et on sait
pertinent bien que c'est pas vrai mais
que faire est-ce que vous pouvez donner
une proportion d'entreprise qui agissent
de cette façon
je veux pas donner de chiffres mais
beaucoup oui
chacun sa chacune sa voiture sa télé
et peut-être les démons jusqu'au
supermarché
faire un petit panier le matin du
dimanche
les femmes dans la boucle douce et dans
la Manche
les polos d'attraction vraiment ne
manquent pas
qui est là qui se trouva de pain
à quoi servent les statines
[Musique]
si je me lève le matin comme maintenant
là je vais chercher du boulot je me
promène dans Vénissieux autrement je
dors
j'ai que ça à faire bon je me lève vers
12h je mange je vais faire un temps en
bas je remonte vers 2h et demi 3h je
regarde le film comme tout le monde le
feuilleton l'après-midi là
après j'attends et à mon collègue il
revient du boulot avec ta voiture et
puis on écoute la musique on va en ville
on se promène et puis vers 8h30 et on
rentre chez nous et on rouille jusqu'à
minuit 1h du matin c'est un peu
désespérant s'il fait froid comme ça
c'est pas la peine on regarde le film
et les gens ont peur je les médias m'ont
fait tellement de tapage là dessus que
moi il y a un fournisseur qui m'a dit
est-ce que je peux vous livrer madame
est-ce que je risque rien c'est quand
même énorme ça nous porte un temps
considérable
[Musique]
le seul lieu de réunion pour les jeunes
c'est cette galerie marchande il n'y a
que deux cafés trois trois café
comment expliquer vous non il y a des
salles communales aussi il suffit de
demander
qui n'est pas garni de jeux mais où ils
peuvent se réunir ils sont tous ici dans
les cafés d'ici
de faire une réunion probablement et
comment expliquer vous que c'est qui a
fait ce soit fermé à 8h j'explique ça
parce que après 8h ou même 9h en ferme
du côté galerie et ils sont ouverts à
l'extérieur mais à partir d'une certaine
heure il n'y a que des bagarres alors
les propriétaires sont obligés de fermer
voilà alors que peuvent-ils faire le
soir rien mais comme les autres il y a
un cinéma
c'est cher non non
il ne veut pas dire le mot mais bon
pratiquent un sport les équipements ne
manquent pas pourtant les 3000
adolescents qui rouillent au pied des
tours ne les fréquente pas il préfère se
rencontrer à la maison des jeunes
[Musique]
il y a pas de terrain de sport s'il y en
a mais c'est
il y a des terrains de foot
il y a une piscine il y a tout un tas de
choses non
les piscines et tout vous y allez une
fois après vous en avez marre et en
dehors de cette maison qu'est-ce qu'il y
a comme lieu de rencontre
on est contrôlé par le CRS et les flics
alors on est obligé d'aller dans les
allées aussi
et les boîtes de nuit
pourquoi
j'en sais rien
on sait ça
qui rentre mais ceux qui rentrent c'est
qu'ils ont
léchés au patron de la boîte
comme la colline il faut le dire la
colline
passer à douane pour papier bon je dis
je suis l'heure africain
on a un pour centrage
pourcentage
qui tiennent la boîte hein
il existe entre les jeunes non pas entre
nous entre nous vous pouvez parler entre
nous dans la preuve c'est que regarder
lui si si c'est un mal avec nous au
début
si on lui fait du mal parce que c'est
il est là c'est lui le témoin
ensemble c'est tout il y a pas de
on est bien ensemble quoi c'est tout
quand les gens de l'extérieur ils vous
disent les Minguettes les baguettes il
se passe ça les magatisent pas si vous
allez là-bas on se fait agresser on se
fait voler moi je vois pas tout ça moi
je suis fille algérienne bon dans la
famille il faut pas parler avec les
garçons et tout moi je parle très bien
avec les garçons dans le quartier on
discute très bien on arrive on s'entend
bien il y a pas de il y a pas à dire
voilà on m'inquiète il se passe ça les
garçons c'est des vrais sauvages les
garçons sexy c'est pas vrai ça quand
vous prenez un garçon vous discutez avec
lui il discutez avec vous mais sûr si
vous allez lui dire ça l'arabe il va
vous sauter dessus ça c'est tout à fait
normal
[Musique]
ils veulent faire leur vie comme tout le
monde
ne sont pas fainéants c'est le travail
qui manque travail quand ils vont chez
quelqu'un il trouve il donne une agence
il leur donne une agence ils vont se
présenter il se met il se mettre bien et
se mettrai bien pour aller se présenter
et puis leur disant vous écrira voilà
c'est le mot qu'il répond pourtant leur
a donné des études on a tout fait pour
pour eux quand on travaille pas en faire
et on peut rien faire
de l'école à 18 ans il tourne en rond
vous voudriez partir d'ici
j'ai eu trop d'ennuis et vous avez
trouvé ailleurs déjà on a trouvé mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dans et
demander renseignements et puis ça leur
convient de parler
les autres HLM
on donne de mauvais renseignements sur
vous
en fait vous êtes bloqué
vous êtes obligé de rester ici on est
obligé de rester ici un jour peut-être
en déménage pas
pour certains il est difficile de
quitter les mains guettes pour d'autres
impossible d'y trouver un logement et
vous cherchez un logement ici au
minguette pas spécialement magnet c'est
pas que ça m'attire tellement mais
c'est-à-dire ma mère habite au minguette
j'aurais voulu habiter à côté d'elle
pour les enfants pour
on sait jamais vous avez fait des
démarches démarches j'en ai fait
beaucoup même et le résultat négatif
négatif qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit
qu'est-ce qu'on me dit le contingent est
dépassé le contingent c'est simple tout
est Méru je vais aujourd'hui je reviens
d'Amérique Givors j'étais vers
qui travaille là-bas et
j'ai essayé ma chance un peu partout en
fin de compte à Vénissieux on vous a dit
le contingent est dépassé mais qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire
c'est une formule c'est tout c'est clair
et c'est net puis c'est tout ça veut
dire quoi ça le contingent de quoi
dénigrer
malgré que les appartements sont vides
malgré les appartements sont vides mais
ils préfèrent les laisser de vide que
les relouer à des gens qui ont la maison
je sais pas il y a pas mal des gens qui
demandent des appartements
moi spécialement moi je on vous a dit ça
ici oui on m'a dit ça ici ailleurs j'y
vais en Grigny et vernisons
Pierre-Bénite mon permis
pour le moment chez ma mère avec avec
vos enfants avec mes enfants j'en avais
combien j'en ai trois
1800 logements sont inoccupés deux tours
de 60 appartements ont été murés la
raison en est simple ceux qui en ont les
moyens partent ils laissent sur place
les plus pauvres ceux qui pour vivre au
moins de 20 francs par jour par famille
depuis septembre les départs se sont
accélérés 40 appartements se libèrent
chaque mois
quoi cette tour ce qui t'aime comme ça
non parce que c'est les HLM ils ont
décidé de fermer le bâtiment au début
ils ont ils ont décidé de le fermer mais
en envoyant des lettres et en disant bon
voilà vous devez déménager sans
relogement sans indemnité sans rien
pourquoi je sais pas ils ont décidé de
la fermer comme ça bon on a fait des
manœuvres des réunions des on a amené
des syndicats avec des HLM ça fait que
maintenant une horloge on nous donne un
des appartements et nous indemnise le
déménagement mais ce qu'il y a c'est
qu'ils veulent mettre les Nord-Africains
et les Noirs tous ensemble dans le même
quartier en bas là si moi je vais
déménager ailleurs non il me demande de
déménager de ce tour pour aller en face
ça sert à rien
cette politique de relogement la porte à
côté accentue la ségrégation sociale une
ségrégation qui engendre inévitablement
les cités ghetto c'est justement cela
qu'il faudrait éviter
quant autour vide quelle doit être leur
avenir que faut-il faire de ces
immeubles trop hautes au regroupés de
ses appartements trop grands ou ne
peuvent loger que les familles de 10 à
12 personnes faut-il les réhabiliter ou
faut-il les détruire on en est là
aujourd'hui
réhabiliter une tour coûterait 600
millions de centimes la démolir 100
millions il faut choisir
je pousse en ce qui me concerne l'idée
de démolir quelques tours et de
reconstruire à la place des logements
adaptés de niveau 2 3 4 étages avec des
garages avec une participation de la
population à la conception du logement
et ensuite à la gestion de manière à
sortir de ce cercle vicieux et de
montrer qu'ici au Maguette dans des dans
un cadre réadapté on peut faire quelque
chose mais est-ce que ces appartements
seront destinés au même population alors
c'est à
discuter avec principalement la
collectivité locale mais dans ce que
nous avons dit jusqu'à présent nous
entendons ici
loger les gens qui s'y trouvent encore
et leur donner une priorité pour un
logement ici un logement nouveau y
compris bien sûr la population immigrée
ce qui permettra de lui donner des
logements peut-être plus adapté aux
compositions de famille au type de vie
etc mais pas question pour nous si l'on
détruit de faire une opération
de reconstruction de standing ou visant
des catégories sociales qui ne sont pas
ici si l'on fait cette opération c'est
bien pour donner assez catégories
sociales qui sont là un meilleur habitat
et pas pour changer de créneau si je
peux dire les up sont été conçus par les
technocrates de l'époque parce que on
sortait de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
les familles s'étaient reconstituées et
se développaient pour se marier plus
qu'aujourd'hui les gens étaient chassés
de la terre et venaient travailler en
usine et il y avait un grand nombre de
problèmes à régler du point de vue du
logement les rapatriés d'Afrique du Nord
par exemple
il fallait donc à cette époque
construire vite rapidement beaucoup et
économiquement lorsque la loi a créé la
communauté urbaine les communautés
urbaines ont dépossédé les maires d'un
certain nombre de leur pouvoir et en
particulier celui du logement autrement
dit on m'a enlevé le droit que j'avais
de contrôler la tribution des logements
et on a transféré ce droit à la
communauté urbaine de Lyon qui
évidemment on a usé et abusé en amenant
dans ma commune comme à vos emblins
comme ailleurs ce que l'on ne voulait
pas sur le territoire lyonnais
c'est-à-dire
problème les familles
asocialement difficile les familles
pauvres
résultat de cette concentration de
difficultés dans un espace réduit la ZUP
des Minguettes est devenue un véritable
bouillon de culture où se développe à
loisir racisme délinquance insécurité
avec encore l'air le développement du
commerce des armes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou un décor
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont chargés
nous on n'est pas tranquille non plus
français
ou on peut reprendre si on est parti on
est resté 8 jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est plutôt une impression d'insécurité
c'est pas réellement un climat
d'insécurité c'est une impression qui
tous les jours grandissait un tout petit
peu vous avez assisté à des scènes de
violence de sécurité oui j'insiste
disons ou classique rodéo classique
maintenant quelques agressions par jeu
de Pierre par des bandes de petits
gamins enfin de douzaine 15 ans d'années
et j'ai assisté aussi à des agressions
peut-être un peu plus sérieuses mais qui
sont passés très brièvement récentes de
personnes âgées et vous vous sentez
vraiment en insécurité quand vous
rentrez chez vous le savez disons pas
pas spécialement mais la confiance et la
confiance est partie quoi c'est plus la
même c'est plus la même sérénité quoi je
n'ai aucune peur
mais c'est plus le disant et si vous si
vous restiez qu'est-ce que vous
craindriez pour moi-même je crois que je
crains rien pour moi-même je ne pense
pas craindre quoi que ce soit pour ma
sécurité ni celle de mes proches mais je
j'aurais plutôt peur de de mes réactions
en cas de disons de en cas d'agression
vous n'êtes pas sûr de vous pas
tellement on est on peut pas on peut pas
être sûr de soi parce que c'est un
disant c'est une psychose et puis ça va
grandissant alors au moment donné devant
le fait que va-t-il se passer on ne sait
pas donc il vaut mieux ne pas parcourir
ce risque là je pense être plus
important vous préférez partir je
préfère partir oui j'ai un petit peu de
regret parce que disons que ça faisait
10 ans que j'étais là-bas comment vous
iriez jusqu'à vous armer pour vous
protéger non
non je ne dirais pas non mais parce que
je le suis je ne suis déjà du fait que
je pratique une discipline de tirs mais
je ne veux pas justement avoir un jour
à faire des armes chez vous oui j'ai une
arme chez moi et vous pensez qu'un jour
s'il se passe quelque chose de grave
vous seriez amené à l'utiliser je savais
quand vous êtes spectateur à une fenêtre
vous êtes spectateurs impuissant une
fenêtre il y a il y a deux solutions il
y a la solution enfin il y a ce que font
les gens et puis la plupart du temps ils
regardent assis à coup de leur balcon
moi je sais que je pourrais pas je
pourrais pas le faire donc je risque à
ce moment-là d'être amené à faire
quelque chose la morale répond quoi
question de tempérament certains
préfèrent partir d'autres sont prêts à
agir si je pouvais avoir la flamme
pendant la flamme et je nettoierai toute
la tour enfin toute la tour vous seriez
prêt à faire partie d'un comité
d'autorités
quand des gamins à 4 ans
ils nous croisent dans les escaliers ou
dans les escalier ou dans les allées ou
dans l'ascenseur la plus de ta mère
nique ta mère voilà les mots qu'on
entend alors dis bonjour c'est ce qui
répondent mais qui sont ces gens là
et vous pensez que ça il y a pas
possibilité de s'entendre avec eux de
cohabiter avec eux personnellement moi
je veux pas
j'ai passé je pense pas qu'il le veulent
mais moi je veux pas pourquoi c'est des
gens sales c'est des voleurs c'est
pas de qualité c'est des primitif pour
moi
pourquoi
la première des choses c'était pour
emmerder les flics parce que j'ai
commencé trop à nous emmerder si on peut
dire la deuxième des choses c'est qu'on
voulait les voitures mais c'était pas à
n'importe qui c'est à dire c'était aux
gens qu'on appelle balance c'est-à-dire
que quand des jolies font quelque chose
et que eux ils ont rien à voir dedans et
ben il crache oui téléphone alors à cela
aussi ils sont ce qu'on appelle 0 c'est
c'est quand il se passe quelque chose
dehors
et les gens ils descendent
ils attrapent le petit ils attrapent
quelqu'un d'autre et il le fera ils ont
rien à voir dedans mais descendent quand
même à cela aussi bon c'est là où on les
fera pour l'embrouille la voiture
dont vous ne connaissez pas les
propriétaires il y a eu des voitures
pour les voitures volées
des voitures comme ça c'était pour
s'amuser c'était pour faire des courses
d'abord entre nous et après on faisait
des courses avec les flics ouais on
s'entraîne quoi pourquoi vous avez volé
des grosses voitures toujours
parce que
[Musique]
au début c'était pour c'était pour
montrer aux femmes qu'on connaissait
c'est pas la montrer qu'on savait
conduit
et puis blague la deuxième des choses
c'est pour montrer aussi à tous les
jeunes qu'on connaît que on n'est pas
des retails c'est quoi ça c'est
quelqu'un qui a peur
[Musique]
c'est fini maintenant je travaille pas
mais c'est fini mais pour les autres je
sais pas enfin il y aura un paquet qui
est sur mon chemin mais il y en a
toujours vous aurez beau leur donner des
ronds ou un boulot ils font toujours ça
de toute façon
la voiture ça a beaucoup
alors si on a un collègue une voiture
c'est bon mais comme la plupart du temps
les 6 7 à sortir une voiture ça suffit
pas alors on envoie une
on sort avec
ne demande qu'à travailler finalement
les les marginaux ceux qui nous ont
causés un certain nombre de problèmes
sont une minorité cette minorité
maintenant est en prison pour la plupart
puisqu'on en arrêté une quarantaine les
rodéo ont cessé les incendies également
reste les autres ceux qui ont besoin
qu'on s'occupe de et je ne se sont
plaintes d'actions de racisme de
certains policiers
je crois qu'il faut être extrêmement
prudent avec la manipulation de ce terme
de racisme le racisme c'est une tarte à
la crème que manipule chaque fois que
l'on veut démontrer que la société la
police en particulier n'ont pas à
l'égard de du marginaux l'attitude qu'on
voudrait qu'elle est si je vois des plis
qui se baladent de soi
contrôler les papiers même sur le
trottoir
ici il y a des soucis qui volent
[Musique]
ici il y a des enfants qui craignent de
s'emmerder
vous étonnez pas s'ils se mettent à
voler
après tout le font que rendre la
pareille
et tant pis si vous en font perdre le
sommeil voilà sans eux
un samedi matin je me rappelle bien il
devait être 8h30 9h je me lève je
regarde par la fenêtre je vois un
fourgon de céréales devant l'allée comme
ça oh mais bientôt ils vont venir chez
nous ils vont dormir chez nous on va
être en permanence avec nous ils vont
dormir chez nous ils vont boire le café
ils vont manger
notre réaction c'est voilà on a une
réaction de réactionnaire c'est-à-dire
suivant leur fête à eux on agit
d'ailleurs je sais pas moi il y a un
flic qui vient comme ça il s'énerve il
cherche son arme et tout il joue
l'Américain bon là il a envoyé il prend
plein d'insultes derrière l'oreille bon
on lui dit tu es pas dans un film
américain on tombe pas un film là range
là ou tu sors ça tu vas jamais tiré
range-le ou quoi que ce soit sinon des
fois ils sont comme ça là avec l'arme à
la main
c'est un peu plus un jour ils vont en
plan B ils vont dire ouais c'est pas
fait exprès j'avais oublié j'avais pas
fait
garçons nous quand nous voyons c'est
tout mon aimerait bien qui viennent
aussi nous demander des papiers pourquoi
spécialement s'attaquer aux garçons a eu
bon ben ils sont vachement agressifs
avec eux ils les provoque et puis de là
on devient les disputes avec eux et puis
après bien sûr ils se remettent mais
nous bon moi je dois encore dire que
jamais encore j'ai eu la police venant
vers moi agressif donne-moi tes papiers
n'ont jamais encore non justement nous
il nous évite et j'aimerais bien savoir
justement pourquoi il nous évite le cas
où il nous manque de respect c'est
fréquent qu'ils arrivent puis qui dit ça
vous êtes encore dehors vous les [ __ ]
montez chez vous des trucs comme ça quoi
je sais pas moi il y a pas le couvre-feu
en France alors je vois pas pourquoi il
nous dit de monter chez nous et pendant
le Ramadan il y avait des mères elle
s'était acheté sur l'herbe là eux ils
s'ennuient
comme ça puis le rendu allait monter
chez vous mesdames comme ça après je
suis venu vers nous avec leur Mata comme
ça
c'est dans la vie courante il se lève le
matin il sort de la rue tes papiers il
les rencontre à tous les coins de Dieu
il y a droit mais non à Vénissieux tous
les gens oh tous les tous les honnêtes
gens on pourrait dire honnête entre
guillemets tous les jeunes adjo
maintenant ils chantent insécurisés avec
tous ceux qui se dit et tout parce que
la plupart du temps je sais pas des gens
qui viennent discuter avec nous en
banque qui diront regardez-moi ces
voyous c'est ceux qui nous ont jamais vu
qui nous connaissent même pas puis qui
se permettent de nous juger qui diront
ça alors à ce niveau là d'accord eux ils
ont besoin des flics parce que ça les
rassure quand il les voyent parce que
sinon s'il y a pas de flics ils écrivent
des tonnes de lettres au merde c'est
tout ce qui savent faire de toute façon
est-ce que vous pensez que on voit que
l'attitude de la police a changé là ces
temps-ci il parle avec vous c'est tout
nouveau
l'attitude des des flics comme vous
dites à changer mais avant ce qui nous
est subir avant nous le ressens encore
c'est pas parce que maintenant ils ont
changé que nous automatiquement va
changer avec eux non parce que nous nous
ont fait subir des trucs incroyable moi
je vous raconter une épopée avec ma mère
qui s'est passé ma mère parce que mon
frère ils l'ont pris pour un délire un
vol qui n'a même pas commis d'ailleurs
bon ça passe de ça bon c'est de la
commune ou pas il va me donner le
commissariat pour ma mère est arrivée
mon frère est en train de se faire taper
par terre là alors normalement réaction
d'une mère automatiquement le plus jeune
homme elle dit non je peux laisser mon
fils comme ça ils ont osé taper une mère
de famille
moi le gars qui l'a tapé moi ça doit
être un flic n'importe quoi moi
je laisse par terre moi je vous le dire
moi je laisse partir mais c'est ça taper
une merde de famille qui a dit gosse
c'est pas possible moi je sais ça existe
pas sur moi alors comment voulez-vous
que nous on est bien avec eux non non
ils seront bien avec nous on change mais
il faut que tout le monde change nous
aussi eux aussi faut pas qu'il y en a un
de pourri et puis nous on est on est une
vingtaine de pourri non ça se fait pas
ça faut que tout le monde charme là
d'accord je suis entièrement d'accord et
on sera bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça se passe pour moi c'est tout
le contraire de ce qu'on dit
c'est-à-dire pour moi ils sont très
gentils avec moi ils sont très
sympathiques ils viennent au camion ils
viennent pour dire bonjour pour discuter
pour avoir un petit moment de détente
l'autre
de plaisir de vous voir bon mais ça
c'est les trucs qui font plaisir et
c'est ce qui demande c'est tout ce qui
demande qu'on les considère qu'on les
estime et puis voilà puis nous le
rendent très bien
non
je leur ai toujours fait confiance et je
regrette pas
jamais jamais justement j'ai toujours
été tout seul dans mon camion j'ai
jamais eu une arme ni quoi que ce soit
surtout pas l'été c'est 2h du matin 3h30
une fois j'ai fini alors je suis surtout
la nuit d'ailleurs j'aime mieux la vie
que le jour en plus et tout ce qu'on a
dit alors sur les maquettes mais c'est
les gens qui ne connaissent pas qui ne
vivent pas puisque moi j'y vis dans la
ZUP j'habite pas mais j'y vais j'y suis
12h par jour 14h donc je suis toujours
avec les jeunes qu'on critique je suis
qu'avec ce live faut dire ce qui est non
c'est pas vrai quand on les connaît très
bien mais ils sont formidables c'est ça
qui est terrible moi personnellement
c'est mon point de vue j'ai jamais eu un
problème quand il me font crédit ça
m'arrive mais ils viennent me rapporter
même 10 centimes c'est peu alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut le reprocher
qu'est-ce qu'on peut
ils ont leurs problèmes aussi il faut
reconnaître mais je trouve quand on les
considère comme des êtres humains qui
sont et bien c'est tout ils vont le
rendre c'est pas plus compliqué
[Applaudissements]
maintenant il y a des gens ils voient
les problèmes qu'on a ce qu'on ressent
fais-moi un café
il y avait juste la municipalité de
Vénissieux qui nous écoutait encore
obligé de brûler des voitures pour des
gens viennent et nous écouter
comme le député et Madame Sublet
sur voiture jamais à Vénissieux
[Musique]
la le film il a commencé
comme il y a deux trois jeux de son
montée à l'Assemblée et nationale à la
Chambre des députés là est-ce que vous
croyez sincèrement que si repas eu des
voitures brûlées ou des vols de voiture
comme au mois de juillet est-ce que vous
croyez sincèrement que des gens ils ont
amené là-bas
[Musique]